hello and welcome to data in the
following video i will show you how
easy and uncomplicated you can evaluate your data
directly online with the app
for this you go to the
datatec de page and get the statistics
calculator
then you click on table teachers and
add your own data  in this
table 1
i simply use the example
and the variables that you
want to evaluate appear below is
important that you make sure that
the names of your variables are in the first row in
these tips you will now find the
methods you need to  evaluate your data
on the first day you can evaluate your data
descriptively you can, for
example, display the mean value or the
standard deviation or
you can create frequency tables and
cross tables
on the next day you can carry out a large number
of hypothesis tests
datatec will help you find the right one
test to find
an example you have in your  r survey
men and women
asked about their salary now you want to know whether
men and women differ in terms of
salary
to find out you want to find out the
variable income and gender from
datatec knows which test is suitable for your
question and suggests the
independent test  before the
requirements for the test for
independent samples are not met
you can also calculate the non-parametric
test den man holt new test of
course you can calculate with the sap and
many other prosthesis tests
you get, for example, a nominal
variable with more than two values
For example, a
variant analysis is automatically calculated for the location, which means that
datatec always suggests the appropriate
test depending on which variable you
select which motors are there, of
course, you can also use
datatec to easily
calculate a correlation analysis, a regression
analysis, a main component analysis and a
cluster  a  nalyse so that was
a first overview of the
possibilities of datatec for each of the
methods that duh can calculate you can
find
detailed tutorials here under tutorials, for example for
the perpetrator is for independent
random samples or for the variance analysis
or the correlation analysis also
on our  youtube channel over there
you will find many videos per datatec is
explained and generally useful
information about statistical data
evaluation and now I wish you a
lot of fun with data tab